as we kick off beauty week i can't have
thought or dreamt to have done it with
anyone
like you when do you feel most beautiful
i have to say i feel pretty beautiful
talking to you because it's amazing to
talk to another woman you admire
and bounce back and forth with her and
look at her beautiful
bouncy hair you've really bouncy hair
thank you it's all mr daniel it's
thank you mr daniel for blessing us
and i feel beautiful when i'm directing
i love
to feel like i'm in charge but i love to
do it in a way that's gentle
and in a way that honors other people's
creative process and just to gently move
a process along and to express
my vision and bounce off someone else's
and i love to just wear those headphones
and wear those boots and tromp around
and like
midday on a long shoot day and like
you've just had your
third coffee of the day and you're about
to like charge up a hill like that's a
really good feeling
i relate to you because i feel like i
grew up
i was like an adult i wasn't a kid i
never felt like a kid
i was always interested in a
bigger picture thinking living in
conversations even when i was young
you know i didn't live my childhood in
the public eye the way that you did but
i've lived a very pivotal period
you know from 23 to 34
um under a specific kind of scrutiny and
i think
watching the way that you have navigated
that
so gracefully and that you have actually
carved your own path and actually
decided to define your own chapters
that's something that i've taken a lot
of heart in at moments where i felt like
other people were maybe making those
definitions for me
so your journey has not gone unnoticed
by this
little wanderer thank you so much
for that one of the things i love about
you
and that i've tried to do a lot in my
life
is be open to listening to all of it
and putting it through your own funnel
you know however you interpret
it a lot of people it's hard to hear
everything it's not easy takes a spine
and a sense of humor
yeah and there have been times that
people have told me things by people i
mean the public
that have been really important for me
to hear things that were really
important for me to hear
and there have been times that i've
received criticism
that i knew was the voice of
a system a patriarchal system a system
that didn't like to hear noisy women a
system that didn't like to hear
you know women who wanted to talk about
their bodies women who want to talk
about sex women who want to talk about
their libidos women who
didn't want to talk about their anger
and i really had to try to separate
what was useful and valid criticism that
i needed to internalize in order to grow
and become the person that
i knew i wanted to be and yes it does
take
being able to really hear and also
really be able to laugh at yourself
lena's journey to self-love has included
some
serious health struggles she lives with
ehlers-danlos syndrome which causes
joint pain and other issues as well as
endometriosis for which she underwent
a hysterectomy at age 31.
now you talked a lot about health you
mentioned the body and
just everything um that
a lot of people are not comfortable
talking about they're not comfortable
listening to this is men and women this
is a
a genderless issue will you talk to me
about your health where you've been
where it's at now because i have been
wrapped in your journey as a woman
well that means so much and and from the
beginning of my
health struggle something that i was
really committed to was the idea that i
was not going to keep it a secret
because
we're in a culture that sees illnesses
weakness
we're in a culture that sees sick women
as hysterical women
and we're in a business you and i that
doesn't look kindly on illness
because we people are working at such a
pace
with so much money involved that for
someone to
be in any way unable to show up
or potentially you know a liability and
so i wanted to bring it out into the
open
you know i i knew for a long time that i
was sick with endometriosis it caused an
enormous amount of pain
health challenges um but i also knew
something deeper was going on with my
body
and so i undertook an exploration and
came to understand that i also have
an underlying health condition called
ehler danlos syndrome
which is a connective tissue disease
that causes
like diffuse musculoskeletal pain and a
number of other sort of
random but interlinked symptoms i also
have a form of autoimmune arthritis
that is associated with it and so i also
deal with autoimmune issues at the same
time and so
all of that came together in my 20s to
make a pretty miserable when i wasn't
treating it to make a pretty miserable
health picture
and sort of culminated in my having a
hysterectomy in one of my ovaries
removed at 31 which was
you know terrifying not just because it
was a massive surgery but because
i really want to be a mom and had always
thought that i was going to do it in
the traditional way and i don't think i
realized how much i was going to grieve
that and how intense that process was
going to be
and i have to say though the process of
being able to be open about that
and write about that and understand how
many other
women how many other people how many
other couples
have grieved that alone and together was
one of the most healing things
i've ever experienced
you